on friday jake
said the word you heard me say the word
once and then i walked outside
and then i walked back inside and then
you walk back outside and i walk back
outside then you walk back inside that's
160 by definition yeah because every
time it doubles
160 until i do 160.
the issue is
when i was filming he was only able to
do 16 and he never finished the last 64
and that was on friday today's tuesday
rule states that whenever you leave a
location it doubles saturday sunday
monday and a tuesday and he just walked
out of the hall again
god god knows jake has an infinite
amount of push-ups owed to the game of
life gods when he when he gets back
we'll do the math with him
i don't know how i need i don't you're
not going to cash in on all these
push-ups there's no way no he's going to
be in the infinite debt
so i got a question for you
what'd you do this weekend
why
what you do
what sort of trap are you walking me
into right now nothing what do you do
this weekend where did you get i went
out with my motorcycle club i
uh hung out with my daughter i was at
home a lot i had a pin bend in my ar-15
and so i replaced it well it sounded
like to me you went somewhere with your
motorcycle club yeah okay then you went
home you went to clean up your garage
went back into your house worked in my
office i worked on that's in kind of the
same place yeah got a lot done around
the house jake
friday you went home with 64 push-ups
still owed to the game of life yeah i
see where this is going i thought about
this when i left on friday
dude
one two three four i need two i need to
sue for peace let's do it i gotta double
this eight times if it would appease the
gods of the game
to have me
carve my gold you're in debt by 16
325
this isn't chicago
this is the wild [ __ ] west consider
me like floyd mayweather right now
pre-mcgregor fight okay i owed a bunch
of money to the irs on tax from money
that i made from the pacquiao fight okay
but i didn't have the money to pay it
but if you gave me if you give me some
time
to have another fight
then instead of instead of the irs
losing out on 28 million dollars they
can get all that money but they're gonna
need to wait this is a similar situation
you can come to an agreement we can do a
payment plan yeah i mean it's like we
need to come to a situation where you
know everyone wins because you're not
going to get all that why don't we just
talk about some steven's bucks for a
little bit 30.
damn i was hoping you wouldn't think
about this i got home on friday and i
was sitting there eating dinner
and i just looked up and went
and i realized
i know dude i know
there's two ways out of this we can
figure out a value
of equivalence between a number of
push-ups to steven bucks we can do the
more entertaining thing which is for the
next year until next september 5th you
do 45 push-ups a day
it's like a student loan i have a game
of life mortgage
[Laughter]
oh no
a game of life mortgage i could see this
as an opportunity and wake up every
morning and curse carmichael's name and
do 45 push-ups
[Laughter]
how about this how about this how about
this i got a solution
five stephen's bucks go to the bank and
i will do 45 push-ups a day
till the end of this year okay so half
it's literally half yeah 68 push-ups a
day for the rest of this year no
40 push-ups hey i'm agreeing to 40 a day
plus five stevens bucks which is which
is equivalent me getting it done by the
end of the year is equivalent to the 22
that you lose
per day i
so
okay
60 so the total 16 384 equivalent to
10.9 surrounded down to 10 10 steven's
buck half of the stevens box you have 68
push-ups a day to get through
if you decide to do 45 per day
the banks are losing push-ups what i'm
saying is what i'm going to guarantee in
this arrangement is i'm going to get it
done by december 31st 2017. you you
can't be too stubborn about these sort
of things this is this is this is
you have a deal thanks nick thank you
thank you thank you two-thirds agreed we
have a deal
all right so starting today 45 push-ups
a day yep for the rest of the year
in the bank yep
all right let's get it going
day one
[Music]
i feel like you're pretty happy about
the deal of not going for 365 days
they're only going to get easier from
here right we want to try something new
for the rest of this week for the next
seven days will be a daily vlog marathon
so please hit that subscribe button
share and tell people to come over and
watch this because you love it so they
should love it too thanks see you
tomorrow